一つだけあのエピソードがありますね
悟る可能性がなくなった人のね
これ最上の話だと思いますけど
私はこの場で何回もそのエピソードをね
まあ紹介してたことがありますね
まあ一人息子が生まれて
億万長者の家で 金金貨の貨幣で数えたって
もう金の貨幣でね まあ十六億でしたっけ
まあまあ八千四百ですからね
かっこいい数字はね で
それ億と まあそこまではないでしょうね
まあ億万長者親ですね
だから親が計算するんですね
まあ人間には一日生きるためにはどれぐらい金がかかるのかと
それで計算すれば まあこれはもう三年生きていたってもね
この財産は消えませんと
計算しちゃうんですね
それでまあ自分の子供は大丈夫だと
幸福に生きてやる だから勉強させる必要はないと決めたんですね
しかし ある面ではしっかりしていますよ
何のために勉強するのかと
勉強って宗教じゃないんです
私はよく言ってる ただ何か食い物探すためなんです
何か腕に技がないと 食べ物入らないんですよ
現代では金が入らないんですね
だから金で必要なものは買ったりしますからね
だから もっとわかりやすく丁寧な言葉で言えば
ただ餌探すためなんです
皆様は本当に誤解していますよ
私はすごい品のない言葉使って
それはすごくわかりやすく意味を凝縮して覚えやすく言ったら言葉なんです
だからこの正しく単語使わないんだから
皆様に皆さんは真理に気づかないんです
学問とは素晴らしいこと
何言うのかと私が言ってるでしょう
あの子 すごく頭が良くて
天才みたいで これもできてこれもできてとかね
褒めるところじゃないです別に
ただ餌探しにはうまくいってるんだと
結構餌はこの人にはありますよと
だからゴルフに頑張ることも
野球選手になろうとするのもね
もう別にスポーツ選手にもなんでもないんです
あれで簡単に餌に見つかります
つきますからね そういうことで
あの なぜ技術知識学ぶのかというと
もう生きるために必要な品物を得るためでしょうに
だったらそれあるならば
何のために学問かということになるんです
だからあの両親がしっかりしていたようなところもあります
それで勉強はさせなかったんですね
何一つ 遊んでいればいい
もう一人の家でまた一人娘で同じぐらい金があって
同じ家柄で それ同じ考えで勉強させなかったと
それで二人が結婚したら
もう財産全部一緒になっちゃって
なおさら もう話にならんやと
自分の息子の財産だけでも年食っていられるのに
あの家とこっちが結婚しちゃったらもう六年も伸びますから
喜んで結婚させましたけど
親が死んだところで まああっという間に全ての財産が消えちゃったんです
それに親が気づかなかったんですね
だから心配するべきところを間違ったんです
こいつをアホで置いておくとね
こんな大なる財産の管理はできなくなるんだと
だから普通の家よりも
うちの息子がものすごく頑張らなくちゃいけないんだと
億万長者であるがゆえに
他の人よりも億万分は頑張るはめになりますよ
そこを間違ったんですね
考えを だから苦しみから抜け逃げられません
皇太子として生まれたんだからって
なんて幸せな奴かと 逆です
誰がいでも苦しいんです
人生は 他の若者がやることは一つもできないんです
それはイギリス王室はね
もう何でもかんでもね
すごい現代的で開放的だからね
どれほど苦しいかと みんな知ってるでしょうに
だからチャールズさんの息子たちが
もうごく普通の人間よりもすごく厳しく
あらゆることをして生活していますよ
だからイギリス人が人殺し殺すこと好きだからね
イラクだって言って 本人が自分も実際の戦い場に来て頑張りたいんだと
でも軍隊はもうこれダメダメだと
困りますよと もう王家のね
まああの なんとか系 系
なんとかやってる人々だから
やっぱり守らなくちゃいけない
と言っても いえ 私はこのチャールズさんの息子やったことじゃなくて
ただの軍人でしょうと
だからみんなと同じ分やりたいんだと
だからそんなことやらなくてもいいのに
なんでそれに挑戦するかというと
その生まれた家の問題なんです
お坊ちゃんでは済まないんです
だから軍人上の人々はあなたが行ったらもうわざと我々は狙いますよと
だからあなたが勝手に頑張ろうと思ったって
あなた行くことで我々も一緒でなくなります
だから例えばそれよりいろんなこと言ったって本人行ったんですよ
で 今のチャールズさんにしたっても同じでも
どれほどの訓練能力があるかというと
キリがない 今やらないんだけど
飛行機の操縦もできるし
もう馬に乗れるし あれもこれももう何か聞いたらできるというね
それで終わりかというと
それでも哲学で言ったら出て下さいと
哲学も学ぶし 宗教も学ぶし
あらゆる文化も学ぶし
大変ですよ もう普通の人には比較できないんですね
苦しみは それでも何かちょっと失敗したらグタグタ言われるし
だからこの そこはもうやっぱり生きる苦しみからはね
たとえ王子であっても逃げられません
あの親がそこら辺は計算できなかったんですね
逆でしたですよと こと何も学ばなくていいっていうことじゃなくて
おかしいや矛盾だと 人は金のために学ぶのに
金があるならばその分もっと倍に学ばなくちゃいけない
何やこれって この人生の矛盾に気づいて欲しかった
すべきですね だから初めからもう 100万円の貯金がある人が
ものすごくその 100万円をどのように管理すればいいか
どのようにすれば長く使えるのかと
すごく頭を使わなくちゃいけないんですね
頭はもうお金 1円もなくて
頭だけ使って何か学んだ人は
その都度その仕事をして
1万円  10万とかもらったりするんだから
もう何も考えなくていいんです
手を動かしたら金が入りますからね
そこを使って終わる形でまた仕事をすればいいんです
だからどちらが楽かということはないんですね
しかし 我々の頭ではやっぱりいっぱい貯金があった方がなんてありがたいかとかね
生まれる時いっぱい金がある家で生まれたら最高ですねとかね
何考えてるんですかね
それが違い 矛盾ですよ
人生生きることは 大きくて生まれたら申し分はないんだと
じゃあ逆ですよ 本当は
ありすぎ問題は だからこの正しいこの人生っていうのはもういつでも矛盾だ
本当に貧困どん底で生まれた家族には苦しいですねとあなた方言ったっても
すごく喜んで ギャーギャーギャーギャーと何も責任も感もなく
気楽に鳥たちと同じく生きてるんだからね
結局は 食べるものもないくせに
もうろくに着るものもないのに
インドに行ってみたら
大量の子供たちはもう学校にも行かないんです
だから考えてもすごい気楽にいるんです
誰かに手を出せばいいんだからね
だからああいうことで
もうなんとかボランティアで行ってね
なんとか頑張って学校を作ってあげたって行かないんですよ
そこでまた別な子供たちはちゃんと制服を着て
もうもうものすごくニコニコ笑って
普通の日本の子供たちとすごく明るくて
日本の子供たちよりもすごい体力高く
もうせっかちの人々いますけど
いいなとこの子供たち思っちゃって
その子供大変なんですよ
恐ろしい もう戦争してますよ
教育戦争 だからまあこの人生の矛盾っていうのはね
ずっとついてくる問題です
はい だからそれで それであの夫婦の場合はそうなって
あっという間にあのものすごい大金がね
もう消えてしまったんですね
だから金の管理できないし
計算できないし 家来はなんでもやってくれる
それは勘違い 家来やってくれませんよ
家来を管理する能力がないとマスターに
意味がないんですよ たくさん家来がいるんだからといって
だからそれ矛盾で 結局はいっぱいお世話する人々がいて幸せですねとかね
料理作ってくれる人々はいるんだと
料理の専門家が 危ないんです
自分たちがものの見事にその世界知らないと何作ってくるかわからないんだから
で ある雑誌でやりましたよ
あの自分の態度はちょっと悪かったらね
高級レストランでウェイターたちは食べ物に唾液かけないと思いますかと
違います 必ずかけますよ
だからかっこよく食べてください
高いお金払って だからお金あるんだからといって胸を張って行くんじゃないんですよ
それで言ったっても すごくもう挨拶をして
もう感謝の言葉もかけて
ちょっと褒めてあげて
機嫌取ってあげないと何食わせるかと知ったものじゃない
うん だから金がある人はね
もう料理のプロをずっと雇っていたんだからといってね
その人に 主人に能力がないと
だからそう簡単に調子に乗って生きていられませんよ
ちょっと昔の話ですけど
もうある日本の人なんですけども
もう大バカもんで とにかく会社で社長になりたいだけなんですね
それで必死で とにかくそれで大きい会社はいくらか分配して
あるセクション 別な名前をつけて社長にしたんですね
この人 社長にしたんですけど
この人の面倒を見る全体の人
やっぱりまたいくらか仕事できる人々は入れておいたんです
この人は俺が社長という気分で
もう仕事内容を調べません
自分でビシビシと調べてこうしなさい
ああしなさいということもないで
お前ら仕事やという感じでやってください
向こうもいろいろ資料を持ってきたら
もう社長だからね ハンコだけボンボンボンボンと
そこでまあ 百四十億ぐらいの赤字で
もう会社を倒産しましたけどね
私 あの連中に裏切れたと
どういう風にという それさえもわからないんですね
私に説明も何も言わないで
自分たちで仕事をして
もうハンコだけ押してもらって
結局自分の責任になりましたと
自分の責任でしょうに
だから能力なかったら社員でいいんです
社長になったならば 隅から隅まで知っている人でないと
便所掃除まで目の見事にできる人でないとなるもんじゃないんです
だって何か失敗したら文句言えないんだからね
全部知ってると思うと
下の人々は怖いんだよ
やっぱり真面目に頑張らなくちゃいけないんだと
だからどちらの生活楽ですかね
社長の生活？普通の社員の生活？結局同じでしょうに
給料が高いんだからといって
それよりもどれぐらい仕事するのかというと
これも成功する人々の話ですよね
私が言っているのは成功する人々の話
負けの話じゃないんです
成功する社長っていうのは最悪なんですよ
人生は 小さなことにまで
気がいかないと だから 50万くらいの給料の人はいいですね
社長がもう 100万の給料もあって
車もあって あのもう会社で作ったすごい家もありまして
家賃も払わなくてよかった
あれやこれやとかね 温泉さんも付いていてとかね
そう見えるだけね 表面的には
だからいつでも人間というのはこの世の中で
ちょっと調子に乗った途端倒れちゃいます
はい まああの夫婦はね
まあ最上にいたこの もうそれで 1文もなくなっちゃって
家ももう他人のものになって追い出されて
何も生活できない それで夫婦は乞食になるんですね
何もできないんだから
そこで祇園精舎のところでは
お坊さんたちには布施もらいますから
残りは全部捨てます いくらたくさんもらってもその日で捨てます
だから普通の乞食の人々は
まあお寺で休まくるんですね
お坊さんたちがご飯食べて残ったものは全部もう外へ出しますから
で 簡単に何か食べ物をもらいたいと思って
この二人が若いんですけど
乞食になって座って もうお寺だからもういろいろそんな乞食に乞食らしいにギャーギャーとやらせませんだから
ちゃんと並んでもらって座ってもらって配るんです
それでこの二人もご飯もらって食べてるんです
全部もう一旦お坊さんたちが食べて残したものですよね
結局 自分の鉢でもらったご飯でしょうに
だから鉢一つしかないしね
だから結局そのまま食べてるんだから
一旦食べた食べ残しなんです
お釈迦様がその日あえて外へ出たんです
で ずっと乞食の人がご飯食べるところをずっと歩いている
じゃあまた他のアーナンダ尊者らみんなもう自分たちの残り分は人に上げて
次のお坊さんが自分の残ったものを次の人にあげてとかね
やってるところで お釈迦様
アーナンダ あの あの若いカップル知ってる？知りません
あんた知らないの？あれはね
ものすごく有名な何とか何とか家の息子と娘だよと
アーナンダ ものすごく乞食で
どういうことだと あの家柄の人々だから
あいつらは自分たちでね
人生は失敗しましたと
その二人がね 若い時勉強したならばね
この国の一番のトップの座に座るんだよと
豊かさに 座る能力はあったんだよと
もしその時がそれを置いておいて出家していたならば
悟れる可能性ありましたよ
今どちらでもないんだと
その時ははっきり言ってどちらでも失敗やと
ということは その夫婦がね
やっぱりこの人生よりはやっぱり出家の方がいいと思って出家しても
やっぱり出家する人はいないんですよ
結局 だって身寄りないんだから
身寄りない人は出家させるのはもう悟りに達するという成長というかね
気配があれはなんです
だったらお釈迦様進んであんたね
何やってるの？出家しなさいとはっきり言うんです
そんな苦労して何よと
例えばスニタという人がこの不可触民族の便所を掃除するカーストの人で
一般人と顔を合わせてはいけないカーストで
これででっかい人の金持ちの家のトイレのものは全部もう入れて入れて
もうあの下水ね 行くとこずっと向かってくるんですね
この人すっと隠れるんですね
隠れたらそちらに来るんだと
顔を上げなさいと なんでこんな惨めな生き方をするのかと
これでいいと思ってるんですかと
言ったら その人はこんな惨めで意味のない生き方だと私は知ってますよと
しかし 私はどんな道を選べばいいのかと
これはもう運命で もうこういうこと
だったらお前は出家して修行したらどうですかね
とってもありがたいことですけど
身寄りの良い私はね どんな宗教でもね
受け入れませんよと じゃあ私が出家させますから
その場でそのまま立ち上がって
じゃあ行きな 行きましょうと
そのまま連れて行ったんです
それで出家な 私は認めますからと
一言葉で出家なんです
儀式何もないんです お釈迦様の場合
で あっという間に悟りに出してたんです
それでその人をお釈迦様はかなり宣伝に使ったんです
隠さなかったんですから
家を 王様にも言って拝まされるんです
顔合わせてはいけないカーストですけど
この人はもうものすごい聖なる人間だよと
神々も頭を下げて拝むんだよと
それはとてもありがたいこと
王様もあんた知ってますよ
この人どんな家の人かと
有名なタレントさんが宗教に参加して
そういう宣伝じゃないです
お釈迦様は 人間社会に捨てた人
こんなところまで上がりますよと
だからこの やっぱり心理学は心理学だから
これどうにもならん 我々の感情の解説ではね
人が苦しんでる時助けるべきではないかと
あれは倫理論理だけ 人が会社も倒産して
あれやこれやとやりたい放題やってホームレスになったら
だから助けるべきではないかとかね
これは論理だけで なぜ助けなくちゃいけないんですかね
自分の行いでそんな結果いたんだから
だからそこら辺は助けてあげなくちゃいけないっていうのは
失礼な言い方で 助けるべきやっていうのは観念的な言葉で
そういうところじゃないです
すごく中道的で 何するべきかということを発見しなくちゃいけないんです
だからこの 私がずっと言いたかったのは
このポイントは あの 何か愛着
観念的な概念に愛着をつけて
フォンにして 生命が生きている
それで生きていることがわけがないと
フォンは壊れるわけじゃなくて
フォンの観念がなおさら強くなるんですね
愛着 煩悩がなおさら強化して質の悪い愛着
煩悩になるんです だから金が欲しいと人々は金
頑張っても金が入らない
仕事を探して面接受けても断られたりすると
もう失敗者でしょ 盗んででも金取ってやるぞと思っちゃうんです
だから金欲しいっていうことは強力になっちゃったんです
初めはどこかで労働でもいいんだから
あの安く給料でもいいんだから
何か仕事くれと大人しかったんだけど
贅沢するつもりも何ともなかったんです
ただ家賃を払って何か食べるものぐらいあればいいという
すごく普通ノーマルでしたけど
そこでいろいろあって断られたと
それで包丁を持ってコンビニに行く
だから金がない 食べるものがない
住むところも追い出されるんだとかということもあって
しかし仕事を見つからないというね
あらゆる失敗の条件が揃ったところで
あの感情が消えなかったんですね
強烈になっちゃったんです
そこをまたかえって輪廻の恐ろしさというかね
輪廻の矛盾なんですね
若い子の子の場合は 女の人に話しかけたところで綺麗さっぱり断られて
もう無視されちゃったと
それでも一人にアタックしてみると断られると
やっぱり私はもうモテないなとかね
まあいいや 女はとかね
勉強しますということになりますか？なりません
逆になる 勉強もやめて女の人に口を出してやるぞということになる
昨日でしたっけね もう高校生の男の子がもう一人殺しちゃったという
理由はシンプル まあ別な学校の女の子に気に入ること気に入っちゃって
で 付き合いましょうと言われたんですけど
断られたんだと それで断られたなぜかというと
自分を知っている他の男の子友達なんですけど
その二人が仲良く友達になって付き合ってるんですね
こいつはその男を殺しちゃったんです
十九歳だから大人として扱いますよとニュースで流しても流しましたけどね
だからノーマルで行かないんですよね
もうまあ じゃああの女の人にはアタックならその友達がいるんだからとかね
にはならないんですよ
他の女の子に挑戦してみるぞということにはならないんです
あるいは逆に成功者だったらいいやよということで
もう三人とも随分仲良く友達になって
もう本人があんた二人と一緒に行きましょう
どこかへとかね 本人がもうどこかに三人と連れて行って
すごく遊んで 公園やら映画館やらあっちこっち行って結構遊んで
その時ずるずると女の子にすごく親切に
じゃああんた二人行って
私はポップコーン買ってきますからとか
そういうことをずるいことやったら
あの女の人もやっぱり
この男の方がもっと気が
勝てるのに  子供のことだから
それはどうってことないでしょうね
大体あの年ではね 何人も交代するかと思うと
数が切れないんだからね
だから子供の世界の付き合いだからね
そういうふうにいかないんですね
また私にアドレスしたら
私はそういうずるいことを教えてあげるんです
もう大したことじゃないんだからね
たまたまお互い仲良くやってるだけで
それで運命同体ってことでもないし
だから女の子だっていろんなもう同じ年の男の人々と仲良くして
友達で遊んでみた方がよろしいし
男の人もみんなと仲良く兄弟みたいな感じで一緒に生活して
それで性格合う人々はそれぞれそれぞれつながりますからね
そんなに真剣にならなくても
やっぱりそういう方法もあるんだっていうことさえも気づかない
逆にあの女の子に対して異常な愛着が生まれただけ
初めは普通 だって友達になりましょうだけの話ですけど
[笑い]そういうわけで生きることも苦しいし
これ失敗しちゃうと この心にある愛着
煩悩っていうのは超過失といっちゃいますね
で 悟れなくなっちゃうんです
道が閉じる だからあの子供の人生はもう閉じたでしょうと
未成年扱いしないんだと言ってるんだから
それで例えば これ仮の話
例えばその子はそれでもう裁判も受けて
もうそれでもう何とか両親はなんとか言って
例えば私に手紙でも書いて
なんとか瞑想でも教えてくれとか
うまくいくと思いますか？いいか
教えてくれと教えますが
やっぱり一つ失敗した人はもう一つも失敗する
はい そういうことですから
この人は家というものに家というんですかね
ホームというものにという観念にね
愛着 執着をつけてずっと頑張って生きていく
生きることが まあそれなりにうまくスムーズにいけば
家という愛着っていうのはそんなに気にしなくていいということになるんです
例えば 外国に行ったところで
外国でうまくものにしていくとホームシックにならないんです
外国に留学しようかなと思ったら
行ったところも良くて
自分がホームステイしてるところもすごく楽しくて
もう勉強もできて うまくいってるならばホームシックにならないんですよ
親が心配して電話かけかけない限りは
電話さえもかけないことになっちゃうんです
しかし ホームはあるんでしょ
その人もあるんだけど
あの愛着がね 薄くなっていくんですね
それで外国に行ったんだけど
もう寮なんかに泊まる羽目になって
そこでいろんな国の人々が来て
それで性格はむちゃくちゃバラバラで動かなくなったりすると
あと 外国人の挨拶の仕方もありやこれは何でも違いますからね
時々もうああいう学生同士でもドアを叩く時でもポンポンじゃないんで
ドンドンと叩くんだから
日本人だったらものすごく怖くなりますよ
そうなってくるとどうなりますかね
一気にホームシックになっちゃう
それで泣きながらお母さんに電話するんです
家に帰りたいとかね だからそこで感情がもうかなり強烈になる
だからその人はもう負け犬で日本に戻ったら
それから人生は負け犬の人生になっちゃう
結果 ちょっと待って  そういうことですから
まあ心理っていうかね
心理学というかね  そういうふうになっています
人生は無常です 生きることそのものは無常です
お釈迦様おっしゃっている法っていうのはそんなもんなんです
それは破るものなんです
その感覚が その観念がある限りは苦しみは続くんです
破る方法はサティ 気づくことで
瞬間瞬間の現象を見るしかないんです
実際にあるのは瞬間瞬間に変わる現象です
何が固定したものはないんです
すべて合成 合成 合成 合成ばっかりで
現象 現象 現象ばっかりで
現象というのはたくさん原因で
もうあるのように現れるだけ
音楽っていうのはあるのように脳の起こる現象で
音楽は存在しないでしょうに
だからサティが必要になるんです
今度こちらで書いてないのは
ウイジュンジャンティットというのは何だということなんですね
ウイジュンジャンティットっていうのは
この頑張っている 努力する
励む 興味を持つ サティマンドというのは阿羅漢たちはということなんですね
サティがある人っていうのは
わかりやすく阿羅漢たちはなんです
頑張ってますよと 法もないのに何頑張ってますかね
そこはないんですね いわゆるサティが完成したら
阿羅漢になったら やることは全部なくなったっていうこれはないんですよ
誰よりも活発なんです
だから悟った人から見れば
あんた方死んでるでしょうにと言うんでしょうに
腹が立つでしょ 私も時々腹が立ったら言いますからね
あんた死んでるんだからとかね
阿羅漢に言われたら逆に腹が立つと思います
こんなに頑張ってるのにとかね
徹夜して頑張ったのにとか
この仕事は三日間頑張ったのにとかね
まあ死んでるんですねと言われると
頑張ってないんです 機能してないんです
全部止まってるんです
ほとんど 昨日いい例えを思い出したんです
昨日ある本を作っていたんだからね
生きてるっていうことはね
私から見れば あの漁師さんって魚取るでしょ
魚取って そのまんまあのビニール袋に入れて
水も入れて空気も入れて
店に運ぶんですよ そうすると
このスーパーでも生きたまんまの魚が売ってるんです
私は見るだけですっごく気持ち悪くなるんだけど
見るんです で このあの貝のいろんなものとかね
あのプラスチックの皿に入れて
もうビニールぴしっと閉めてますけど
あれじっと見たらもう生きているんです
あの味噌汁に入れるあれ
小さなものを何て言いますか
しじみ あれ 小さいうちに取りますけど
結構大きくなりますけどね
放っておけば 子供の時殺して食べますけど
しじみなんかはもうほとんどあの生きたまんまで売っている
じゃああれ生きていると言えますかね
ある日 どこかのスーパーに行ったところで
この発泡スチロールの箱があって
あの木の粉 あの 何て言いますか
粉 おがくず おがくずをいっぱい入れて
氷も入れて その中何か売ってるんですね
見たらエビなんですね
その中に入れて もう元気なやつらがね
パッと飛び上がって落ちたりもする
で 店の人はまた元に戻す
あれで元気で生きてる？って言える？ただ死んでないだけでしょう
だから煩悩に襲われて生きていること
あれと全く同じじゃないかな
[笑い]だから世間の生き方っていうのは
オナクツ オガクズの中にいるエビと同じですよ
大したことじゃないんで
たまたま飛び上がったんだからってまた戻せますから
エビどうせやってること何一つもやらん
できんでしょうに また生け簀も作って
いろんな高級レストランなんかではね
やってるでしょうね 私は行ったことはないんだけど
調べるんです 一応何でもかんでも
そういう店では外でも宣伝として魚を見せるように
私はずっと待ってじっと見ているんです
値段を見るんです これはどれぐらいですか？とかね
入りはしませんだけど
誰か一緒に じゃあそんなに欲しいんだったら買ってあげると
断りましてね それは話別ですけど
やはり見るんですね これって命ですか？と
生きているんですか？と
あの生け簀で言うんですか
あのね タンクにいる魚たち
喜ぶべきですかね 人生は
で テレビで見たんですけど
どこかの店ででっかいそうやって水を入れてなんかタンクがあって
それでお客さんが網を持ってもう魚取るんですね
で 取った魚 店で料理して食べさせると
こんな残酷なね 文化っていうのはね
命に対してはもう一番何も尊敬がない
尊厳 気持ちがないんですよ
それで結果として ちょっと女の子に断られたらもう殺す
殺すというね 私はこの子供のことは心配しますからね
一番この気をつけなくちゃいけない年ですよ
教皇聖っていうのはね
もう本人も何やってるか分からない年で
大人か子供かさっぱりわからない年で
本人もわからないですよね
親もわからない うちの子は大人ですか？子供ですか？とも
だからやっぱり守ってあげないとね
一番大事な年で だからこう
私はそういうところを心配したりするんですが
自分が自分の国の同じ年齢の連中がね
まあよく知ってるのは男の子ばっかりですけど
やっぱりいろいろ女の子のことは気になっちゃうんですね
あの連中に誰が気になっちゃうと
これもう焼き付くんですね
脳の中に ね これも我々大人だからもう可愛いんですよね
もう何も見えなくなっちゃって
もう焼き付いちゃって
しかし みんなお互い知ってるんだから
他の同じ年の男たちもみんな知ってるし
女の子たちもみんな知ってるし
そうするとみんな一斉にこいつをからかうんですね
偉そうな大人らしいこと何かやろうと思ったら
何か横から来てなんか俺言っちゃうんですね
すごい恥かけられたりもする
で 何 他の友達は何言ってるのかね
お前いくらあの子に挑戦しても
あれはダメだお前にはと
[笑い]あの子はお前にはもうできませんよと
取ることはすることはできませんよと
諦めなさい こいつはもう私に思わん
こいつはね あの子に諦めませんよと
釣れないのに言ってるのにとかね
すっごく恥ずかしくなっちゃうんですね
そういうふうにクタクタやられることで治るんです
殺してやるぞって これまるっきり出てこないんです
だから そういうところ
私も気をつけて もう恥かかれたら
それは何とも言わないで
子供には悪いしね 後で私は個人的にすごく親切にいろいろいろんなアドバイスしたり
話したりして それでなんとかうまくいったり
もう精神的な状況がうまく守ったりはします
で だからこの命の尊厳というのはね
少ない場合はね 本当に人間っていうのは危ないんですよ
もう何か罪を犯して人生を全部閉ざしてしまうというね
残酷な結果になっちゃいますね
残酷な生き方すると はい
それで煩悩がある人が生きるっていうことは
あの程度の生き方なんですよ
社会で元気で頑張っていると言ったっても
あの この この なんだ また忘れちゃった
おがくずから飛び上がるエビみたいな感じで
確かに元気なんですね
他のエビよりは でも何の意味なのかと
だからあのホームというね
あの感覚が消えた人は自由で
誰にも掴むことはできないんです
生きているんです 本物の本当の意味で
だからうゆんじゃんっていうのは
しっかりと頑張ってるんだっていう言葉を使っていて
何にと言ってないと置いてるんです
なんかお釈迦様は言葉一つ欠けてるんではないかと思われるかもしれませんだけど
お釈迦様の言葉だから
あまりにも超絶した知恵で
それはものの見事にそのオブジェクトというかね
対角の言葉を 必要ですよ
何に頑張っているのかっていう言葉がなくて
私は頑張っているって言ったら意味がない言葉でしょうね
私は勉強を頑張っていると言わないと
なんでそれ抜けたのかと
生きているっていうことだけ言いたかったんです
明るく 本物の明るさで
本物の活発 アンダガタは
おがくずの中です 生きてる
生きてる おがくずの中
という差をつけたかったんです
だからちょっと４行なんですけどね
どれほど生命の真理をね
語るのかと で 注釈書は私の解説ほど難しくは書かないんです
注釈書では 自分の超越した知恵のことやら
サマーディのことやら
そういうことはもう全然日夜もう頑張っているんでしょうと書くんですね
それは当然毎日やっていることだから
私はちょっとそれはあんまりそんなにシャレな言葉じゃないと思いますね
お釈迦様が落とした対角の言葉がない方がよろしいんです
超越したサマーディやらね
ニハンゲダッスやら そういうところにもうすごい興味を持って頑張ってと言ってましたけど
もうあかんんですけどね
まあもっと簡単な例で言えばね
あんた宿題をしたらあの漫画本買ってあげますからと言って
子供が宿題をする もう一人の子供はそんなこと約束何もなく
私の宿題だからやりますと
どちらが活発ですかね
何かの餌で釣られてる人
突然 いえ 私は気が変わったんだから漫画本買ってあげないと言ったら
あいつは宿題やめるでしょうに
だから本という この 何と言いますか
獲物に釣られて生きてるんだから活発とは言えませんよ
[笑い]阿羅漢はフォームはない
ない 何もしないということでもう達してるんですね
はい えーと まあそれではもう解説は終了ですけど
まあ結構難しいんだから疲れますね
こういうの 大乗経典よりは敵わないんですけど
ブッダの言葉にはね まあ一度は比較的に大乗経典もみんなと一緒に読み上げたい気持ちはあります
それはすっごく悪い 何て言いますか
この いじめっ子的な気持ちですけどね
もうどれほど品のないのかっていうことは
まあ証明出して見せることもできないわけじゃないんです
ただ 自分も個人的には触りたくないんで
気持ち悪いといえば気持ち悪いんですかね
比較して見せますけどね
もう一つ大事な解説は抜けてます
このニケータ イっていうのは
私はあのニケータもあるし
オーカもどこでも同じ単語なんです
あの その観念的で心の気持ちと言ったでしょ
しかし 何かがないと観念も生まれませんよ
何の根拠もなく観念というのは生まれますか？原因もなく生まれるはずがないです
それは何なのかと 何でフォームという観念を作るんですかね
そのフォームという観念が作り出した実体は何なのかと
それが本物なんです フォーム
まあ皆さんもう何年も勉強してるんだから
もうとっくに知ってるでしょう
体ですか  そう 五蘊です
色受想行識という あれは五蘊そのものにビッタリと執着しているんです
だからこの体なんです
フォームは だからフォームからはなかなか逃げられないんです
結局 この体のために 体に支えられて
体に依存して 体のために生きてるんです
死にたくはないっていうのは
体を壊したくはないって意味なんです
だから輪廻転生するんです
死んでもまた体を フォームを作るんです
心にはフォームがあるっていうことは
もうある もうもうもう切り離せないんです
だったら死んでも心は続いちゃいますから
当然フォームがあるんです
だから死で終わらないんです
フォームという感覚があれば
だから あのニケータっていうのは色受想行識という五蘊
五取蘊のことなんです
阿羅漢にも五蘊ありますけど
取蘊じゃないんで取が消えちゃうんですね
執着の取ですね だからパンチャッカンダ
パンチャウパーダナカンダと専門用語で分けてます
パンチャッカンダでは五蘊
肉体 しかし 一般の人々の場合は肉体ではなくて執着に値する肉体なんです
感覚ではなくて執着に値する感覚
だからそこで明確にするためにパンチャッカンダ
パンチャウパーダナカンダと
だからもう小学生にもわかりやすくというぐらいのシンプルで語られてますよ
こんな難しい教えは だからこの繰り返し似てる
似てるでしょと ルーパカンダって言ったのにウーパウパーダナカンダって
もう同じことですよ そんなシンプルじゃないんです
そこを気をつけて そういう風に分けてます
色蘊 色 受 蘊と あの執着の「執」も入れてする
その差は何やというと
色 五蘊だったら阿羅漢にもあります
受蘊は悟ってない人々のこと
それをもう一人だけでもわかっている人がいたんだから
大変ありがたいことで
説法は全く無駄になったわけでもないんですね
これ大したもんですよ
もう言われたことは なかなか勉強する人でもいきなり聞いたらわからなくなっちゃいます
はぁ もう次の偈に行きますか
そこら辺でいい加減にやめますかという
オウカ オウカっていうのは
あの この世とあの世っていう
まぁ往還 往還ですからね
まあまあ 家から家で 家
なんかそこら辺はね 往還
往還 往還で話に出たら輪廻を捨てるという意味に読みますからね
この世 あの世で言ったっても
この世というのは今生きていて
あの世というのは死んでからまた生き続くという意味ですから
まあ輪廻ですね まあそこら辺に終わっちゃうと偈ですからね
まあ一応節を完了しないとね
法律を完成しないとね
よくないんだから で は最も難しいんだから
まあ一応今日はまあ遠慮します
よく難しい